la rue evariste de parny est situé dans
le quartier de la marine à
sainte-suzanne une rue à errer au cours
soigner ou les maisons sans prétention
abrite bon nombre de retraités de
l'usiné de bois rouge le labeur et le
temps y ont-ils effacer le souvenir
d'evariste de parny vous savez qui est
evariste de parny
non madame ça ne rigolait pas l'intérêt
de cahill à délais commencent à arriver
pca par l'amba un porte parole à l'ats m
ça comme ça et varicent désiré des
forges chevalier puis vicomte de parny
est né à l'hermitage en 1753 des neuf
ans il part faire des études à rennes et
se destine à une carrière religieuse
mais après avoir fait montre d'une piété
plein de zèle
le voilà qui choisit la carrière
militaire et rejoint d'autres jeunes
créole au domaine de feuilles en cours
il a 20 ans et découvre avec de nouveaux
plaisirs ces dispositions poétique
le jeune evariste on fou amoureux
d'eléonore b mais les familles
s'opposent à leur union
la jeune fille est mariée à un jeune
médecin le coeur du poète en restera
brisé
il repart pour la france ces phrases que
militaire est sévère qu'on soit valère
sa fille avec une malgache ses premiers
poèmes sorte en 1775
il écrit et il voyage en argentine aux
indes
il finit par renoncer à la vie militaire
pour ne plus se consacrer qu'à la poésie
à la révolution ils retrouvent un second
souffle
mais rapidement il est dégoûté par la
violence sanguinaire des républiques
il est rémy ne vend ses livres temps un
hymne à la gloire du nouvel homme fort
bonaparte mais n'en tire aucun bénéfice
en 1802 il change de vie et se marie à
grass valley
l'année suivante il le premier
réunionnais admis à l'académie française
le moral et les finances remonte peu à
peu et puis après trente ans de
séparation réapparait eléonore veuve qui
lui demande d' unir leurs vies trop tard
et varicent ne pourra jamais s'y
résoudre le 5 décembre 1814 il meurt
d'un anévrisme